letztes jahr war premiere auf der
gamescom das größte youtuber treffen
aller zeiten und das war es auch
sensationell tja und dieses jahr gibt es
eine fortsetzung es ist wieder auf der
gamescom und zwar am samstag den 20
achten details uhrzeit usw das kommt
noch wird es also sein und diesmal war
es ein bisschen anders die großen
youtube
werden diesmal aus dem nähkästchen
plaudern über ihre kanäle über ihre
arbeit ihr zukunft alles mögliche was
ihr wissen wollt also es wird mehr
inhalte geben aber natürlich auch medien
greet zusammenhocken sitzen stehen fotos
machen klönen und so weiter und so fort
also es wird riesig sensationell wie
immer und alle weiteren details folgen
jetzt im laufe der nächsten wochen so
dass bis zum 20 8 alles in trockenen
tüchern ist wir die youtuber ich und
alle anderen überhaupt und also wir
freuen uns also ich glaube ihr freut
euch auch es wird wieder riesig und wir
gucken mal vielleicht gehen wir noch ein
bisschen bei programm zusammen also bis
dahin und bis zum nächsten update